popur au fric ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie le
cours des actions renault a chuté la
semaine dernière de près de 11% après
que des contrôles suivi perquisition est
eu lieu au sein d'entreprises ce qui
représente pour l'état une perte
virtuelle de 637 millions d'euros edf
voit son cours au plus bas historique
baisse amorcée dès mai 2014 alors
qu'elle annonçait donc la ministre un
gel des augmentations des tarifs de
l'électricité et donc des possibilités
de développement de l'entreprise
dans les deux cas au départ l'intention
se voulait louable à savoir protéger le
consommateur mais à la fin le
consommateur qui est aussi un
contribuable est lourdement perdant edf
s'enfonce renault va si les décisions
opération de communication souffre d'un
préparation et négligent le fond si l'on
s'attache à renault en menant une
enquête qui cherchent à laver plus blanc
que blanc procédant à des vérifications
de taux d'émission dans des conditions
auxquelles les cahiers des charges
actuelles des tests ne soumettent aucun
constructeur
vous avez mis renault en difficulté et
ébranlé la confiance des marchés dans le
groupe à tel point que vous en rendant
compte vous avez immédiatement tenté un
rétropédalage impressionnant destiné à
dédouaner le constructeur
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas simplement fait
confiance à la représentation nationale
tout particulièrement à la mission que
j'ai l'honneur de présider et dont
delphine batho qui vous a précédé dans
vos conceptions et rapporteur vous
semblez ignorer que nous menons un
travail de fond transparent incluant
bien évidemment la question des tests et
de leur nécessaire évolution ainsi que
la question centrale des technologies
mises en oeuvre et ce dans un dialogue
constant avec les consommateurs
les constructeurs l'europe et l'ensemble
de la filière automobile française
le fonctionnement des marchés
leur fébrilité est une donnée que l'état
que vous représentez à ignorer cela
constitue une faute pour nos finances
bien entendu mais aussi pour les
entreprises concernées et les salariés
quand allez vous renoncer à vous
immiscer dans le fonctionnement des
entreprises qui ferment mal à même la
part de l'état me tue emmanuel macron
ministre de l'industrie et du numérique
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée
je vous prie d'excuser l'absence de
ségolène royal qui est pris par un débat
en ce moment au sénat mais au fond votre
question concerne tout autant le
ministre de l'économie puisque c'est
essentiellement une critique de la
politique de l'état actionnaire que vous
portez d'abord pour vous préciser qu'il
n'ya rien à voir entre les situations
d'edf d'une part et renault d'autre part
pour edf je vous invite à regarder le
cours de tous les énergéticiens mondiaux
vous pouvez décider qu'une commission
parlementaire qu'un ministre que sais-je
peut changer la réalité d'un marché
mondial je serai dans l'obligation de
vous dire que ça n'est pas le cas et
donc si l'action d'edf baisse seuls suns
ce ne sont pas les émissions de l'état
actionnaire bien au contraire maintenant
pour ce qu'il s'agit de renault mais
enfin la confiance n'exclut pas le
contrôle
l'état est dans son rôle a fortiori
quand il s'agit d'une commission
indépendante pour vérifier de la réalité
des tests café la ministre avec
d'ailleurs plusieurs de ses collègues
européens
le lendemain du scandale volkswagen
c'est une réaction de transparence qui
était une nécessité
c'est à dire de vérifier la réalité des
tests sur bancs d'essai et des écarts
qui existent entre ces tests sur bancs
d'essai et en conditions réelles
avez vous entendu cette commission
émettre des messages inquiétants
anxiogène elle a mené un travail
contradictoires professionnel avec les
constructeurs et en parallèle puisque
cela n'a rien à voir avec ces premiers
éléments la dgccrf qui relève de notre
ministère a pour sa part regarder la
qualité des informations transmises aux
consommateurs nous ne ferions pas nos
travail madame la députée
si nous n'avions pas lancé ces contrôles
l'exemple de volkswagen suffit lui seul
a montré qu'on peut avoir confiance il
peut y avoir un travail parlementaire et
ministérielle exigeant si derrière il
n'y a pas un travail professionnel sur
des sujets techniques qui donnent la
pleine transparence la confiance pleine
et entière ne peut pas être restauré la
volatilité des marchés est une chose la
responsabilité dans le long terme en est
une autre et c'est celle que nous avons
choisie
merci la parole les cas madame martine
lignières cassou